hello everyone welcome to another
session of seeing those chess club plays
the people we have again of course our
GM in residence at GM jesse cry with us
he will be playing on chess calm so make
sure you could you go to chess calm
challenges to a game rated games only
500 and three three two is still good
that sounds alright alright 500 and
three two please
challenged us to a game and happy
Halloween everybody I know we have a lot
of international guests out there so it
is Halloween here in America and that's
why we have the pumpkin the pumpkin
right here Halloween spirit
right we were actually going to dress up
in costumes but that didn't really work
out so we're gonna just beat you guys
wearing regular clothes well because
what happened was oh my god well the
thing was you know Jennifer Shahadah she
always has that purple wig yes and that
actually belongs to the club but then
she took it with her so that thing is
missing and I was gonna wear it and
that's a closed purple wig and
Jennifer's rowdy you stole that thing
and I want you to bring it head that's
right
alright so we have okay so we have the
challenge link the link to chess comm on
the chat click it challenge the rated
games bliss time control we have anybody
yet solitaire solitaire ban so out there
bad solid round our regular when I have
regular viewers perfect thank you very
much for everybody thank you very much
for joining us
hopefully we'll get more viewers and a
couple announcements we got a club in
her club rivalry here we got Tracy
upstairs Tracy and Tony been talking a
lot of smack in their battles so when
Tracy puts in her challenge I'm gonna
hand the controls over I don't know how
we're gonna do it but I'm gonna I'll
just move this thing over here and then
Tony can do it I think Tony's gonna get
wiped out I think Tracy's gonna talk
she's gonna she's gonna mess you up
that's cool yeah you ready to start I'm
ready to start harvesting grant
solitarypath been waiting for a while so
we'll take his job oh is the other thing
is we
we are rate Oh No look at that the
rating went back up yeah I think I think
the other rating was like Blitzers
something we're not aware what was it
bullet Danny nevermind anyways we're
playing as always we'll give a shout-out
to our man in the back
Danny Machuca and Isaac Isaac Shawn says
in the back also I just played a bad
move and did you say I was talking about
this move yesterday on my show and
somebody played Knight g3 and I was like
that's a dumb move and then there it is
I did it
however my opponent didn't punish me
because he he didn't bring his Bishop
out let's do it
my chuka said I should play h4 so I did
it I don't know if that's a good move
but you know it puts a little fire into
the position all right let's see
everybody
bar bar sir which is solitaire Babar
soccer oh you're playing right now happy
Halloween
thank you for joining us Danzig oh thank
you for joining us hello we have people
asking for a Halloween gambit please we
will be doing that don't worry I play I
play d4 start it so I think I'm just
gonna play until I get all and gamma I
think in general I'm feeling kind of
gambit II anyway I like it I like it
Daniel Rowe burger hello how's it going
thanks for joining us again Patrick
Dailey hello
if Ben Simon was here he'd be saying
you'll you're welcome so pretty fun
position yep as you guys I don't know if
you guys everybody know this but today
is actually Jesse's last day here the
same low-stress Club as the GM in
residence so he'll probably do something
he probably played a lot of games with a
lot of gambits because he is feeling
gam-gam vicki yeah again but Dean like
that word gambit II
duh now one of the things I made fun of
this move yesterday is you know the nice
just how to play over there so I got it
I got to find a way to bring that dude
back that's gonna be mono I think a
linear one one night out of the game is
is pretty fair - yeah no no I gotta
bring him back in maybe maybe I can
Machuca him with a full-on Knight h5 at
some point but that's pretty bold so one
of our viewers Alex is asking us hi guys
philosophical trash-talking in the cards
possibly we could do something I mean
this is a I mean that kind of thing is
right in Jesse's wheelhouse he's you
know really good at that talking smack
yeah yeah pretty good time yeah you are
you are I mean you guys weren't privy to
this but like right we've before we
started the show we were out in the
hallway and he was just like that's
right yeah Black has a little bit of
gray fear he's gonna have to figure
something all right our friend Patrick
is asking you if you're feeling gamba T
how do you feel about Blackmar gamer
gambit Jesse that's an interesting
there's nothing wrong with a black mark
Deemer we couldn't we could try that we
could try something we're good you know
anything you want to see write it on the
chat and we will try our best to get it
in
in chess there's nothing wrong with back
my redeemer yep Danny in the back is
asking Jesse is there anything wrong
about black man Redeemer in blitz we're
just in chess in general and then Jesse
reply back in general and Danny in the
back gave a little scoff so I'm guessing
he's a Scotty it's not he's not a fan of
it this is called an in-between move
here ouch
that's called an in-between move sorry
sorry about that Matt I'm sorry about
here's a question from Daniel Rowe
burger have you read books of Blaise
Pascal Pascal yeah sure okay we have a
viewer asking Danish gambit please man
you should you should ask that from
what's-his-face that Denis LaRue he is a
Danish gambit theme always ways it I
played Danish when I was a kid yes it's
fun for sure there's kind of a turn I
guess the problem with the Dane o black
played a good move holy moly I better
watch my smokes buddy oh oh moly oh oh
okay oh I just just slow it down down
slow it on down here buddy
you're alright you think I'm alright I
don't know you're right I don't know if
I'm alright look at this guy he's
holding his point oh wait no I'm really
all right here yeah sorry sorry buddy
you spoke to me though that was
Halloween spooks Wow
so one of our viewers Alex
Danny you're in the back cause you
deserve it dang trash talking from the
audience Wow
obviously he is going to be typing
something in to the to come back with
and I'll come back to you
we'll see we assess I'm actually
interested Danny what do you say about
that oh he's saying is true
Wow he just laid back and took it that
took that one day okay so our D to Steve
Martin says
I hate today it's gonna be pretty
enjoyable pretty mellow I think so too
so apparently our friend Patrick said
yay black my redeemer gamut is my
standard opening as white I normally am
okay with going into the French but
against Jesse is kind of hard because
he's played it so much I mean I feel
like he playing against any GM is kind
of a you know same outcome no okay so
you know sometimes I forget the names of
these these black Martin the gammas but
black Martine but we're just talking d4
d5 C 45 right that's what we're talking
about Jesse you're asking the wrong
person
yeah my job my two jobs here are color
commentary and to distract you alright
okay now alright it's Halloween so what
do we want to do I'm gonna try to do
this I'm gonna try to do a different
gambit style okay alright I'm gonna try
to do a gambit every game that's gonna
be my goal okay whether I'm able to do
that see now now I can't really do it so
easy the gambit yeah well I thought
solitaire basses Thank You Jessie thank
you for the game I'll give you a hand
for that soccer bat night
nice try nice try Archie how do you
challenge Jesse so there's a link to
chess calm our profile in the chat click
it hit the challenge button radio game's
only bliss hand control alright five
zero three two whatever suits your fancy
looks like we are counter sparks Canada
yeah
Canadian counter sparks all right how's
it going eh
had to throw that in there actually I'll
tell you what counter sparks if you're
listening one thing I do not understand
you know is what the Freak is going on
in Canadian politics dude oh man okay
maybe you don't want to talk about and I
get it too but I just I can't absorb
that much information about so I can
make it a long story I won't understand
but I didn't understand me it was like
it's hard like we America has its own
weird election system it's hard for
foreign people to understand but I
didn't yeah I have to say I didn't
understand what was going on in that
Canadian election Oh Canada
all right so black mana Deemer gamut is
d45 efore okay Oh see I was thinking
right I was that's why I asked is like
in my mind I was thinking of the the
album counter Cameron which is very
similar but probably better better than
the evil you know the funny thing about
that d4 d5 II force black could just
play a French there nice e6
would be a jerk I think that's what I'm
talking about
all right uh is Faulk beard counter
gambit a good play against Kings gambit
you know it's funny Ike for I feel like
my mind is so old I just kind of
forgetting the names of all these things
I think that's before okay Danny just
giving us a line in the back about about
that so we'll see if that's correct or
not
Daniel Rowe Berger tell tell us a line
tell us the moves for the four first
como moose so we'll try to play it all
right Alec says philosopher and GM can
we call that a double whammy yes you can
absolutely absolutely we like to call
him dr. Jim Jesse that's right you know
both both titles
Hamza how do you challenge there's a
link in the chat to chess comm our
profile click it hit the challenge
button rainy games only bliss time
control 5:03 - preferably so do one of
those
all right have has anybody assimilate in
the audience been keeping track of the
things going on in the chess world no so
you know you tell us what's going on
buddy all right let's talk about this I
have some news pope holed up here so
there it's so the European Team
Championships are going on currently it
looks like Russia is leading in that so
that's cool oh so our so our friend and
our friend charissa yep who actually
comes here a lot you know yours US
Junior Championships US women's
championships she is now the youngest
American female I am ever I think she
holds a lot of different titles were
young youngest American I think she was
the youngest national master feeding
master I think she holds a lot of
different titles but she actually she is
she was currently no she was recently in
st. Louis playing in the spice club and
she scored five out of nine which became
the youngest female I American female I
am ever I like it I like it
do you ever Jesse the ever play Fisher
random oh that's a good question you
know I I did one play the people with
just a calm ages ago and there's a guy
it was like you gotta play it man it's
so cool and stuff so I did play it was
the only time I played it and you know
tonight I'm gonna do a lecture I don't
think anyone's gonna cub cuz it's
Halloween but I'm doing a lecture and I
want to cover some of these Fisher
random games from from the latest a
little championship you know so I'm
gonna be talking about that but I don't
think that's gonna be recorded because
our guy Ben C Mon is too cool to like
come to the club's - too cool well he's
got he's got a life he's out there on
Halloween man said I'm gonna come in
anyway so he's too cool for that but all
I'm gonna do that tonight and I'm very
ignorant with Fisher random I think it's
kind of I think it's a cool idea but
because I'm so old it's hard for me to
learn new things and write I
you know chess is already it's me it's
complicated enough and I can't even
remember the names of all these gambits
hopefully oh my supposed to like master
all the openings enough to say that the
openings now are kind of boring for me
see here someone is behind you are you
referring to are you trying to do like a
Halloween thing there's a ghost behind
us interesting Queen takes dr. TM Jessie
that's the short version right yes it is
yes yes it is we're gonna do a goal of
1800 today how about that okay whether
we get there or not we'll see I like to
go for I like to go for you know the big
let's just try for - mm well we're not
it's just numerically impossible because
we only get like a couple points again
all right I need someone with it I need
somebody with a rating of like 25 above
2500 above two challenges no but even
then we can't we'll play that person one
game
and then that's not gonna be enough
right I need ten of those people
challenged yes see we're gonna get some
games aboard and it's done all right
let's see here to the does it Breanna
all you can play writer gambit which
comes out comes out of the Blackburn
Redeemer gives give us a second pond D
45 here we go this is my favorite gambit
we're doing hey this is my favorite
gambit I'm a big fan of this one we got
I got an a vicious debate online it
turned vicious people let me just say
people got really excited about this
opening where you know somebody like had
the gall to say the ridiculous statement
that they were like refuted like that's
dumb you can't like you know no you
don't refute you don't refute this Smith
more you don't claim to refute it either
anyways yet people were getting hot and
heavy about this refutation the suppose
at refutation and what did i do I said I
said something inflammatory I'm lining
you you don't want to do it man don't
say anything inflammatory online and I
got in trouble so there was all right so
the Reese or the reason I asked about
the Fisher random was because you know
the world Fisher random champion she was
going on yeah of course
so the two finalists are Wesley so and
magnus carlsen Wesley so is both our you
know top players in the world Wesley so
is actually placed on our our our league
team so we have a professional chess
league and he is on the st. Louis
Archbishop's which is awesome you know
one of the top players in the world
honor we have we have that I think so if
Mike was here he'd be giving a whole
spiel about this but so there's no
there's no rate rating cap on the team
anymore so we have like five top players
in the world so I don't expect us to
lose
so the so the fight so that so Carlson
Fisher random finals are beginning today
and it goes on till Saturday so check
that out gonna be pretty fun
don't uh let's see what's up Jesse it's
red shirt I played buck house with you
against Eric Oh Jacob Sanders
I know Jacob did you come red red shirt
when you come right yeah yeah Jacob was
saying this uh aren't you supposed to be
in school right now supposed to be in
school
oh so Danny's Danny's inform you that
you are always on extrema and you're
doing it at school oh yeah man you
better you better be getting like
straight A's so you get that so you can
actually justify that it's go out right
now Oh Halloween 0:03 me like that I
think so is that okay the kids don't
actually go to school anymore anyway
they just hang out on their iPads and
yeah sure that that I think Fisher
random is great for correspondence chess
when played by amateur players like me
who know next to no theory I've actually
never played Fisher random so I can't
comment on anything but you know why not
yeah play for fun try it out I'll
probably play a couple games try it out
see out of this all right [ __ ] weird
counter gambit was seen as a strongest
response to King's gambit maybe has very
strong chess engines degraded its value
interesting interesting
we actually don't I mean do you care to
comment on that do you actually know a
lot about the [ __ ] yeah I think
anything against the Kings gambit is
gonna be good for black it's all gonna
be good you know there's no bad position
there for so so apparently our friend
Patrick is say
he knows been Feingold place to fall for
it again counter gain but is that true
I'm I think it's good I actually you
know all those positions just always
seemed fine to me one of our viewers is
asking you suggest some books to become
really good at chess
have you guys ever read Jesse's book
yeah what about my book yeah what do you
what do you mean read yeah when do you
read his go and go out and buy his book
or it's on did you say it was on up go
do or it's not okay this is turning into
a little bit of a struggle for me homes
what's this guy's this guy's playing
alright oh come on he's just being nice
he's crushing you
I thought he could have checked me over
there I would have been simpler for him
but okay because the problem is I don't
I have a way to talk to him I need to
talk to her
alright let's try this move
I don't like that move either we have a
lot of challenges good and I like it
alright so if you want to play against
Jessie make sure you go to chess comm
the link in the chat and then challenged
us to a rated blitz game so our friend
Alex saying yes I did
he did really well cool cool anyways I
mean what like when you're studying
chess a lot do you I still study chess a
lot I don't know what I'm thinking I'm
so tired right now it's okay
so tired right now I'm trying to save up
some energy so I can go grab grab a
knife and actually carve this pumpkin oh
you're gonna need your you're gonna need
your energy for Tracy but who sees that
her knife ready jeez oh my god I can't
believe it next time next time when I
when I play Tracy not if it's not online
I'm gonna I'm gonna tape it so I have
proof I'm gonna crush her proof that she
stabbed you in the neck that's the only
way she can way it's the only way she
can win if she's physically assaults me
that's how this it's getting boring that
dr. Jessie always wins
dude that's a point that's the part
you're you guys his job is to try to
beat him and it's my job to distract him
seriously I think I feel like Cyprian
has a good it's an interesting position
I didn't like that move but otherwise I
was I liked his position I'm actually
kid Danny I'm curious how many how many
times have one of our viewers beat any
of our GM engine revs playing on stream
when you say every now and then when we
talk about like oh I love it
I didn't I I almost lost you didn't
though yeah yeah I almost lost give me a
guess give me your best guess 1 out of
50 games 1 out of 50 games I mean
typically you you we play what like 10
10 games
roughly every stream right so you would
have to play great have you have you
lost so since you've been in here in the
last couple of weeks
online cheated oh yeah oh yeah okay I
don't I don't have an answer to all my
problems here I'll tell you that right
now and Oh Tracy's on the chat she's
saying I'm studying let Jen build up his
confidence that's fine okay
i I've said this on on on-air many times
I'll say it again in this world the
biggest advantage you're gonna have is
to be underestimated go ahead and say
whatever you want go ahead and say
whatever you want it's cool it's cool
Oh somebody's saying maybe I should take
your drink
maybe that'll give it a chance oh okay
if you think that's gonna help
I don't like I'm running out of moves
and I got to move I don't know what to
do I'm gonna go in there I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna sack this exchanges yeah
I had a good good sack it would a good
sack dude this is not wise I don't know
what I'm doing this was dumb if you're
gonna sag I thought you're gonna go like
rook rook e8 or something give it a
little check a roof - I'm a bum hole
buddy it's gonna get a little hot let's
see Jacob Sanders says I beat one in
bullet three two one
really really which which one is that
I'm curious of so I can actually check
on that fat if that's true or not I've
got to somebody Patrick says I got two
wins against im's and blitz this is
getting hot my friends this is real
spicy right here holy moly
here comes gentlemen here it comes it
comes to the time pressure so Wow what's
gonna happen how is it gonna shake down
Cyprien better move fast
oh he's miss simmering is one of our one
of our regulars I hope you have a chance
here
somebody suggested I should pull your
pull the chair from under you to give
them a chance take it easy
yeah that's let scoff let's you know
slow your roll we don't want to hurt
Jessie all right
Oh somebody is straight-up declaring
I'll crush Jessie in under 30 moves dang
I don't even know how to respond to that
somebody asks how how do you become
better at calculations
oh I survived that one
try try sitting beside it trying good on
the try you know you Tony was
distracting me thank you very much thank
you very much we go back a little bit I
thought Cyprian had a real interesting
position with the two bishops and you
know maybe I played actually you know
here's a funny thing I'll say with this
is I have looked at this position before
where black kind of ditches the pawn
with d3 hmm and it's it seems kind of
like you're not a man that's how it
seems so it seemed to the first in fact
white kind of has to change mood here I
think that was the biggest mess like
boom you got a change not a man and I
don't I didn't want to do like the maroc
see buying stuff like take it just
seemed too lame to me but I think if you
got to do that then white has to like
change up his whole like feeling and I
wanted to play gambit so there we go all
right - oh we got two guys strong one
here your father - perfect perfect Jacob
Sanders you're asking if I want me to
listen name so you remember now bro
remember yourself look it up you're
you're in school I know you're not
paying attention in class so just look
it up yourself oh I was gonna play the
Alvin counter gambit and my finger just
automatically play d6 here we go though
here can you scroll through all of your
challenges to see if I actually
challenged Jessie please yeah well I
remind me when I'm done with this big
guy well what try to get to that because
Tracy though hey Tracy hey Tracy where
are you at
we gotta get you in here she's not going
to she doesn't want to everybody to know
that I'm gonna beat her it was cool it's
cool it's all good it's all good all
right so so the guy who said he's gonna
be doing under 30 moves he's like I'm
just kidding I'm a big fan
oh there you go there you go
Cyprien set a good game yes if Breen put
in a good game yeah don't let me ask you
something what are you you know I'm just
new to this city and they got me
teaching a lecture tonight so I don't
know if I'm to go out but tell me what
is it what does a young man like
yourself do on a fine Halloween night so
I've actually so let me just put it out
there I don't celebrate Halloween I
actually don't celebrate any holidays to
be honest with you this is so weak I
can't even believe I asked that question
what do you mean and also I think ye
what do you mean that's oh wait what
what explain yourself what's what's we
tweaked about that response what's
what's a week about not celebrating
anything give me a break
dude have some humanity see this see
y'all see that but the veins are grant
this is ice in the veins no no no human
no I actually try to avoid you know turn
turn my lights off and make sure no no
kids come to my door kind of thing well
okay so you don't celebrate anything no
okay I get that and kind of a weird so
but what do you do you know you're gonna
go out sometimes yourself no well yeah
so what are you gonna what are you going
possible possibly Thursday right but I
got it what I have to do tomorrow me
think maybe maybe like ash or not cuz I
got a meeting early tomorrow work
meeting you're just loads of fun man
can't believe this now I'm really
thinking about proposing your chair from
1ru it's just just for kicks and good Oh
Dennis LaRue is on the Chinese saying
humanity X clam ok ok yeah all right
Dennis Lee why don't you challenge to
the game Dennis and see and because
somebody that actually asked for the
Danish game is sold less money challenge
to the game just play play it alright
I'm getting a little Susie over here
with Voltas but see somebody's actually
saying Jessie's with Jesse's on with a
real trash talk today yes he is he's
actually talking to me I don't
understand I thought we were well maybe
he's mad at me because I'm now going to
talk about this Balthus feel the power
of my queen oh man we got a little good
rating points there we're getting closer
to 1800 okay wait now I got a look there
was somebody I was supposed to look for
Who am I looking for
oh we're looking forward to do can you
oh it's Archie so his name in in the
chat is Archie Connelly is I what your
chest name is that same thing I don't
see her she commonly yeah that's cool
let's go I tell you what but you you
tell him to get his name get is oh yeah
and our Archie give us your chest ah
calm handle all right we got another a
very tough challenge 2268 here we go how
come I'm black every time what's going
on there but all these sense sensing
that you're your GM so it's like working
oh and this is just straight-up three
minutes all right I got it I gotta go do
we go I gotta go deep Oh somebody's
actually saying hey Toni
aren't you supposed to distract him see
what he's doing - wow you're trolling me
now okay
I'm gonna distract them come on Jesse
what are you doing
take it take it d4e for I'm not even
saying anything relevant he's not paying
attention to me I got it I got a tough
game on my hands here friends all right
tre
see Stewart says I'm trying to do my
tactics yeah like that helps that's
funny that's funny
yeah jesse is a cool guy yes he is very
cool uh in the Psalter basses GM jesse
thank you for the show yesterday these
analysis of sending games are very very
cool oh cool I like that
we got a hectic battle on her has your
friends so Cyprian said he was very
close
no he was close supreme was doing fine I
got my own issues here too man
is this real spicy moment in the game
right here oh yeah this is a real
interesting moment I'm actually trying
to pull up the Fisher random
Championships here see you see what's
going on who doesn't want to see some
top players in the world play especially
a champion all right Queen e1 all right
mr. Knight I'm saying you got to go
buddy okay this is this has been an
interesting game so far that's when you
say interesting is it like no thinking
where are you I'm playing some guy who's
for real here what's this
Oh 2268 Wow okay please don't give us a
lot of points when you win not playing
some jumpier man come on
see Oh somebody's saying somebody
suggested Alex suggested I should use
the pumpkin to distract you the pumpkin
you mean you're like throw Adam I could
do that
Isaac in the back is telling me to throw
it as head which made this which makes
for great great you know great show I'm
not sure if there could be some likely
legal troubles I could get into so well
let me check on that first time you guys
this guys coming at me and you guys are
all talk in this you know blah blah of
course that's my job and this is this
guy I didn't even realize it he didn't
we were supposed to do just three two he
did straight-up three oh not very nice
buddy so Patrick says I actually beat a
2100 USCF over the board with from with
Ryder gambit as well okay cool I put
that game on Jesse's member analysis
thing oh all right
man this is getting hectic the Akash
said play with me just started playing
three months back just started playing
as in like your new where are you coming
back from not playing chess for a while
let's see how I cope with you what's
your chest I can't handle let's maybe
then we'll try to get to you
Stavros said the lecture on Bobby
Fischer and space was really great Thank
You Jessie I thought that was yeah that
was awesome
Thanks this is an intense game man this
guy's this guy's no joke yeah somebody's
falling across bla bla bla ba ba ba ba
ba
all right let's what's going on let's
let's take some bets on this game this
is interesting who thinks he's gonna win
this no it's not okay okay I think the
others oh my gosh that's totally new
okay well uh all right what's your chess
calm hand they'll say we'll see if we
can get to oh I blew it on that but he
didn't take advantage of her it's going
Patrick says he's hit this game is gonna
come down to the clock is that your 34
second yeah pop probably family how
strong is the strongest level of
stockfish Danny how strong the strongest
levels stockfish
okay we have no idea we will so Danny so
this baby is Danny is guessing 3600
that's probably yeah what's they will
say that we'll say that
h5 was winning for white there right he
might be winning anyway buddy I'll tell
you that right now
oh wow that's smoke in my house man I
guess Jesus
I guess this this is looking to be one
of those one out of 50 games it's guy
went on time got time it's all this it's
cool
take it easy on me
Oh
let's uh let's take it easy with it it's
yeah yeah yeah it's a it's a
kid-friendly show here kid-friendly show
your front yeah might get a draw though
I got a draw I like it
oh we gain points right eight points
yeah
alright so meet Akash ah groans did I
drop an f-bomb in there it is that what
I did what happens that was a good game
wait let me just look what what happened
oh it was you know let's you know what
he did he kind of sprung some opening
knowledge on me actually with this move
Queen B 1 then I guess I didn't react
well enough again and I didn't realize
it was three minutes so the Queen props
the Queen B one it poses at least some
real questions for black here yeah all
right good ok yeah yeah you had yet that
going what's this I think we would
cuckoo cuckoo where is he from what is
that country Albania no no it's nice oh
no that was a good move and I thought
actually when he played when he took on
f6 I was like that's probably not right
but no he got a nice initiative here and
I'm sure I could have played better in
here but still he played all right I
like it okay let's play again
let's see what's Tracy's handle buddy
and who we know so my parents so art so
Archie is the guy that you were and we
got to get Machuca get Tracy's handle
cuz Tony's not giving it to me cuz he's
scared I don't even know what it is he's
scred i don't know what it is i try
you better call her too because I think
she's she better not be welshing on us
here oh so Jacob Sanders is referring
back he finally figured out who he who
he beats in blitz and it was Oh in
Bullitt noblets it was I don't believe
that
tipper ooh three three three two one in
Bullitt in the stream in mid-july
is that is that true Danny everybody
sings out it but you know what it is it
is on you YouTube so we're gonna I'm
gonna go go back and check it out I'm
gonna go back and check it out so
somebody's for somebody's from Russia
and he says play with me his handle is
Berber Jacques bird jockey we'll try
we'll try our best to get to you I don't
know what's going on here
now I'm doing all right he could have
done faster check me
I will I'll be checking you don't worry
I'll be checking you why don't you do
your homework doing up school tomorrow
what are you doing in if I remember
correctly you are now I want to say a
sophomore in high school maybe a junior
I feel like a lot of people in those
grades are you know studying you know a
CTE SAT maybe just like maybe general
yeah school in general what are you
doing yeah what are you doing buddy what
are you you gotta have you better have
straight A's that's how you justify you
know doing this Michelle son says play
please play with me okay we'll try it
what's your chest I'll come here no let
us know we'll try to get to you I'll
shake up as a junior dude that's like
the that's like your that's like the
your you have to be focused Foley here I
a CT SAT what's what are you doing
focused Foley were you big on school and
you're a kid very yes
stereotypically you know eight Asian
just studying all the time yeah yeah oh
and you better get Tracy on the line I'm
already really upset
wait what what's what's Dennis is chess
a communal King Dennis
oh that that sounds like him but we see
it we see it we see it okay we'll try to
get to you Tony why was yesterday's
played the people stream not put up on
YouTube
what do you mean isn't Danny is that not
not up oh it's not up it oh yeah it's
it's not anymore because of the you know
non kid-friendly only language that was
happened there oh really yeah I think so
but I did I drop some bombs yesterday ah
I believe I believe so I believe so
sorry about that's cool that's cool way
it happens oh yeah we were talking I was
filming you later [ __ ] okay so okay real
quick I I'm assuming to today's stream
is not gonna you posted also right well
yeah so here's the thing if you tell me
it's not gonna be up then I'm gonna fill
us in what happened yesterday
are we all we need is no proof that's
all we need so it doesn't matter what's
going on now okay alright so we'll get
all filming it later alright um
Dennis Lewis says yes it is King Dennis
you know I could have just taken that
pause what I just take that pawn hello
so Jacob Sanders says taking a a CT prep
class I'll be good and studying you so
okay okay fair enough fair enough
are you gonna take the what is that the
Princeton Review thing is that what he's
man you know all this stuff just cuz I
had to take it when I was in school like
20 years ago
alright couldn't you edit out sound
somebody asks clean yet how sound is
that true yeah you could edit out the
sound
we'll try who's beating who in the back
sounds like angry bees is that really
that's Machuca back there is that just
cuz my mic is rubbing up against my
shirt
oh it's a fridge so are apparently you
guys can pick up the fridge sound wow
that's pretty impressive David said
however how's it going David thank you
for joining us oh here we go let's go in
so our friend from Russia saying
Halloween do they celebrate Halloween
over there everyone I think Halloween is
turned into an international affair
right that's it oh okay I would think is
that is that true and like was it
Germany since you will you stay there
sir yeah everywhere you know and I think
one thing cool thing I just learned
today actually is you know there's a lot
of Christian traditions that are now
Christian traditions that were
originally like older traditions mm-hmm
right like definitely the burning of
safe or having a Christmas tree that's
like Northern European yeah they got
hella berated and apparently Halloween
was like this druidic festival it
sounded something like The Apprentice
pronounced it something like saw Wayne
okay and so I was like this druid thing
that they were doing and yeah I hadn't
known about it I had always heard like
some vague Christian interpretation that
was like what does that really mean in
terms of Christianity now I know it's
actually like them incorporating the
local tradition okay it's something
interesting because the Christian thing
is like some Hallows Eve thing you know
that's how they okay are we playing
I'm Dennis Dennis and I really think
it's time for you my friend to be
playing Tracy I mean I if she wants to
be oh he's gonna play the French on me
buddy
Oh hehe is actually a hardcore French
player so yeah he's a hardcore French
player that's I mean that's pretty bold
concerning just really
let's lay it on the line what do you
think about that King dance yeah what do
you think about that buddy all right so
uh Archie just said good game Jesse all
right there so there's our men our men
in the back put up the link to chest
comm again click it challenge us radio
games bliss time control please five
zero three two
any of those will be great he has played
a330 before and not earlier today so
maybe do that too
so Daniel Rowe burger from Sweden is
saying we celebrate little Halloween but
it's all saints weekend this state this
days
All Saints weekend hmm good to know
thank you for thankfully that's good
good to know interesting yeah Dennis I'm
gonna say like you it's pretty bold
you're playing their French against a
French player it's interesting position
two he's either lost or he's not lost
not there's no draw option here ah
no bully are you interested in playing
bub bullet you know I grew up at a time
when bullet just wasn't even a thing so
yeah I mean you can always challenge it
see if he accepts it and that comes from
Jacob sander so he's a bullet guy he
wants to know he wants to be a higher
level person it's also if I'm playing
bullets kind of hard to chat with people
that's true that's true yeah but I would
say and it within my lifetime what's one
of the things that's happened is several
people have learned to play bullet at
kind of a high level yeah like yeah and
that's just been a surprising thing
right like when you see Magnus or
somebody playing bullet or this kid yang
you know this kid yang who's in from
like Minnesota he played the US Junior
yeah I feel like don't bullet I mean I
don't really watch a lot of little games
where you even play below games but I
mean isn't that just like a lot of time
winning on time kind of thing well you
know there's some waiting on time but
it's let's get this right here Jeff
singer singers reply whoa I'm not God
you were definitely not a guy let's face
facts man
today's facts all right okay we have
some so our friend from Russia saying in
Russia Halloween this this holiday is
celebrated mainly by use in nightclubs
as part of global American culture yeah
good to know yeah that sounds like my Oh
Dennis I'm sorry buddy that was the one
move you weren't supposed to do oh and I
just had one job buddy
Pat Patrick is saying I'm so glad I got
to see we'll see what Jesse plays
against the French nice yeah that's
imaging I got a lot of different things
that was uh by the way if you look in
chess practice by nimzowitsch this queen
g4 idea a pretty beautiful idea there's
reasons it doesn't work okay let's say
it that way but it's still really
instructive positionally to think about
so our friend Akash a girl is saying
play with me next please I'm in in I
mean India time is 2 a.m. here all right
buddy see how you do so apparently he's
a brand brand new player ok well he
playing for like a couple of months I
guess but basically brand new so
Jacobson are saying I'm just between I'm
just in between 1900 to 2000 bullet on
Lee Ches mm-hmm so help me out buddy
where do you what are you doing for
you're not are you going out tonight or
not you've been evading this question Oh
Oh God do you want you want you wanna go
ahead no no something out did I touch
something wrong what happened what
happened did we we here before to hit
the chord
I might have touched the chord buddy
we're on again we're back all right that
that little shadow you guys saw that was
Isaac he just went Oh f3 no boy no
because in bring your guys out whatever
you're doing bring your guys out
three doesn't help you bring your guys
out all right let's see here to the UH
mm solitaire bass says I hate bullet
both were playing and watching bullets
not much of a chess game it's cross
between chess and manual dexterity yeah
some people say that Knight nice mask
nice match gents can you play against me
my username is mins Oh J will try to get
to you
me lolly says greetings gentlemen how's
it going thank you for joining us how do
I challenge so there's a link in the
chat to our profile in chess comm click
it hit challenge radio game's only bliss
sound control please are you gonna
answer what you're gonna do tonight oh
sorry I I can go out you want to go out
extra man I don't have to be able to go
out what well where you're like
lecturing like tonight on your last day
oh man they got me working hard and I
think only two people are gonna show up
so I think we're just gonna hang around
and analyze some positions or something
it'll be pretty mellow
but anyways well how about this when you
try to sell me I'm going out where would
you go
what are you in what are you into are
you so like you know how singsing Lewis
is kind of like a beer a beer town are
you a you're a beer beer fan a lot of
happier I've spent a lot of time in my
life drinking beer yeah but yeah I've
been drink too much recently there's
like there's a lot of micro brews when
you hit out if you're into that kind of
thing are you a club guy you like that
it's nice we could do that I actually so
that was i I did that back in like in
college and I stopped after that because
it was I couldn't keep up I can't keep
up with those guys anymore getting old
getting old oh all right please play me
okay we'll try we'll try to get to
everybody there's no way we're gonna get
played everybody because there's just we
don't have enough time but we'll try
we'll try
he's like demanding that I trade Queens
and I don't really want to trade Queens
here so it looks like we today okay
today is the birthday of Grizz shook
and Alec I'm interesting didn't know
about that did you
I kind of knew about Alec I knelt a
story I Tony here was about to throw
away some books how it kind c22 ancient
rock walls of Alekhine's games and i was
like excuse me Tony no no I'll take
those books buddy let me let me know let
me correct that statement I was not
gonna throw books away so so you guys
know Nick risco who's an employee here
the trestle he plays some people
sometimes he is in charge of libraries
in on the chest campus I found some
books in a basement you're up next buddy
I tried you're up next Chris I'm coming
for you I gave up those books I did not
give up you I was give me I was trying
to give it to Nick Rubisco so he can
manage the books and put in the library
you're you asked can I have those looks
like sure see one of our favorite tea
I'm scorching an apple yeah and now
you're trying to turn it around on me
out no more of that no more mr. nice guy
Tracy's gonna pop you she is no she does
what she does
oh this is gonna be fun he's been
talking smack on me wait does this is
our fourth time we've been do you you've
been sitting there just running your
mouth off and now Tracy's gonna come in
here and spank you hard son running I'm
not really gonna hurt I was assigned
this by my superior to distract you why
are you blaming me on this if he's gonna
hurt you bad it's gonna be rude
can I please play I've seen so many of
these and didn't get a chance max Tempah
knee is that yours is that your chest I
can handle as well well first we're
gonna do this we're gonna the first game
is gonna be against Tracy and and I
can't that she's been challenged me
again again but I can't accept until
this game's over and then we're gonna
get that going and then we'll get some
other people Tony loves to throw books
away by Dennis Loretta how would what do
you mean what do you you know what we
are we are no longer and we are no
longer friends or acquaintances or
anything like I I can't believe this I
can't believe this check this move out
buddy
whack
as a nice have you have you played a kid
named with the handle of giant googa I
don't know so he's a real name is Gary's
from new New Jersey he's actually been
on TV cause I'm glad we he played
somebody else and we look we look look
them up he wants to play you apparently
what's right well first of all try don't
try to get away from not playing Tracy
buddy cuz you're gonna have to play
Tracy I know it's scary we every day you
down
I play Tracy and I know it hurts okay I
know it hurts
I understand how how can you you are you
have kids how can you lie to people like
that you know i betray see all the time
what do why don't you ask her hi Peter
like three through three times in a row
I've been there like three times in a
row hey he's gonna hurt you bad buddy
oh man let's see all your book burning
and your smack talking she's coming here
for the delivery you know I quit I'm
here walk off he's coming buddy
oh man it's Gary Gary sorry Gary
my bad my bad all right we got this now
hold on I'm gonna get I try it all set
up
oh man where's the thing on the right
hand side how come I can't all right
there she is oh she wants three minutes
she wants to beat you fast I'm glad to
be doing this oh my god buddy I'm
hitting the except right here
Tracy retches Tony right ready here we
go BAM you're up buddy
oh my god oh good all right let's do it
yeah Oh II four good move Tracy
good move good move now come out with
the spank no she she likes to do oh so
you're not gonna plate you're not gonna
play f4 ha she used to play C forever oh
there we go there we go away for the
madman stay for the mate there we go all
right Castle early and often Tracy there
we go oh she's just gonna tuck it back
she's just gonna do a little tuck of
course she is little nip and tuck ah all
right you're good oh whoa whoa that's
two days in a row I like that move 92
you made me break the chair because of
that whoa
I broke the chairman man I broke the
table cooking everything holy crap
oh it's toast it's toast I really broke
it this time it really is the force of
Tracey's moves if you guys saw a imagine
across it did you go across to me that
was I Isaac Isaac when you come say hi
to everybody what happened here no chair
broke man yeah we're gonna do oh it's
just like yeah yeah got to lose some
weight here gotta lose some weight
family I'll survive for the next half an
hour but I think it's broken
Tracy I need you to do the spank I like
this little Knight g3 thing you did yeah
me too you too she's gonna oh you're
gonna let her sack on 86 right what you
I'm okay with that
she's gonna come hurt you over there a
second Queen d2 bang come in
oh-ho she's gonna go bug house-style on
you man oh oh she wants to bring the ice
yeah okay okay you know what won't we do
this too are you scared of that night
you want to get him out of there yeah a
little bit a little bit you better be
scared I'm scared are you like crushing
the Stateline you chair braces like this
whole thing it just went clear Casey
they lose on time just move the night
back or something come on if you can't
hear you know oh I don't know Tracy I
don't know Tracy oh you found it dang it
what do mean I thought it's like dang it
I have an engine going on the other
computer guys that's for Tracy f4 let's
start let's get a little counter play
let's go you're not done for yet Hey
calm calm down calm down calm down
f-for with the big spank Tracy bang F
for ya and then light him up with f5
next light him up Tracy I hate you so
much right now five light him up light
him up
you can play down a piece against this
chump he doesn't know anything
there we go Tracy there we go
rook takes rook takes thank you so so
basically everybody if you haven't
noticed yet I'm playing against Jesse
Aaron right now Oh Tracy g4 h 4 let's
start the roller wow are we I'm already
playing as you holy yeah let's go h4
first with the roll I can't believe this
I'm actually playing against Jesse oh
man
whoa Tracy's going yeah take it take it
take that quick now in a real game II
would have lost cuz he would have taken
it and then just that's it game over
but unfortunately chess calm doesn't
allow you to move in this way and Tony
hasn't even figured out yet why he can't
take the Queen nope
so officially Gracie's won this game
it's officially Tracy as my best game
it's only because these weird rules that
he's even alive here that's probably
Tracy play f6 play f6 Tracy Tracy you
calm down you calm down are you gonna
take with the Queen lose your deep on
buddy
yep that's probably wise or take the
deep fried Tracy what are you gonna do
I love playing against Jessie it's fun
all the time Oh Tracy Tracy that's
playing she's playing officially she did
win officially she did what because you
you were gonna play F G and then in a
real
that would have been over cuz she takes
your king oh is that what it is yeah
okay what do I do now play Queen III
check Zoey you want me to yeah click
Queen III chick there we go
I'm playing it cuz he he told me to I
cuz he told me to I'm not even paying
attention with our viewers saying now
yeah oh I need to be doing this job yes
you do yes you do
Queen III know why I did it go here you
three okay what am I going now I don't
know maybe rook 88 or something dude you
know no am I still winning on something
I am I'm fine oh oh yeah Tracy just
don't give up it's all about time at
this point
come on there you go there you go what
else think about it a little bit more me
yeah think about it
I don't want to yeah think about it a
long time why would I want to think
about it for a long long time go Tracey
move move Tracey move bang this game was
close officially Tracey won this game
you can say all you want no she did in a
real game that's it's over and say that
all you want
doesn't mean anything wait one bite I
know what she wanted two different ways
she won the official way and then she
won the time - Oh Jesse - oh you why
don't you stop lying to yourself I don't
get it crushing her she crushed you dude
she brought in the heat and you couldn't
take it
mm-hmm it's okay all right
bring it on bring it whoo Diane Guga
let's say Jane Guga who did you say
giant Google was aa name is Gary
eleven-year-old kid from New Jersey
okay all right how can i play this as a
gambler I don't know that's good
he's thinking about it is this 3 this is
5 I said her and knocking on door what's
happening I don't know
that's the spooky ghost dude
Tracy smoked this fool over here all
right
I vow I can't believe I can't believe I
Isley's actually touch talking smack
right now okay I think it's talking
smoke him twice yeah it was brutal
friends yeah it was kind of brutal
all right here comes now I should've
taken with a night God this is the
second time today whoa what are you
doing buddy the second time today I
misplaced my for night all right let me
go back in the chat here and see what I
missed
oh yeah gary is saying I'm 11 room I
remember you Gary
I remember you 20:50 apparently ha ha ha
I love Jesse so much hello from mr.
Spock hello would you do a lesson about
Korchnoi rook endgames oh that's fun
yeah hi room Frankie hi Frankie please
playing against me to dannika we'll try
GM is too strong for the chair okay yeah
that's right
see here tada
all right tell me trash thanks to Jacob
I'm about to ban you from here it's
gonna be awesome let's see
thumbs up smiley face okay you forgot
about me oh the Russian guy you forgot
on here what's your what's your handle
again please play me Dennis LaRue Tony
stand out be here so we're hoppin oh
that's funny anything that Dennis that's
funny
Wow we'll see you let's see how we're
see where that takes you it's cool but
Tony was sitting sideways to the monitor
and I had to play against Jesse it's
cool no nobody's gonna talk about that
bar bar so I think thanks for putting
that out though it's cool please play me
next I'll be I'll play either of you max
tempani
you still haven't told us your chess
calm hand though what is your chess like
I'm Hannah is this is it max max the ten
money is that their name Wes c1 as white
and Fisher random against Magnus oh cool
you guys should do a stream with class
varying weight with chest variants like
three check chests king of the hill etc
I tell you what why don't you write us
at info on st. Louis Cheska org I'm
still waiting for somebody to do it I'm
still waiting for somebody to write in
and tell Tony rich that I'm ready to
play in the invitational tournament
buddy you know how come I how come daddy
doesn't get to play in the invitation
well you you asked me to get you into
the next fall right fall fall classic is
that what you said I'll play anything
man Tony doesn't invite me to these
tournaments it's pretty stingy of him
man well chief you know I've been here I
do I do my work here for chess calm and
then he doesn't let me play I was
actually gonna recommend you but then
after all this it's not gonna happen
Jesse yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna ask them
you go against you oh oh this guy's
getting spicy oh please play me mitt
mitchellson mistress on 120 which your
what's your chest a common is that your
chest common handle as well
Oh Bert Bert Bert jock was the rep
Russian God you will try to get will get
to you man will get to you
whoa what is going on here I don't know
he's trying to shut my poor business
down
yeah
this get this pretty exciting right I'm
actually not paying attention Oh should
I be paying attention well you know I
understand
after you got beat down the way you did
okay all right I mean all day all day
you know I have a lot of sympathy you
know I really do because when you get
beat down like that just it doesn't feel
good you know it doesn't and nobody
likes it
no what do you like to say I don't think
I'm heartless
I understand I literally do not care
okay you keep saying this like oh I
don't care of any of this
we got a spicy position on Jesse's
four-on-three is real blacks oh but I
got my I got my own problems
no I I miss played this my friends this
is not no bueno here he's got a good
position and you know what I played way
too fast cuz your fault what I do I
wasn't even playing head from the game
wasn't been talking to you it was your
fault buddy that's cool I'll take the
blame for it I'm kidding I'm getting
smoked by this 12 year old kid man
smoked he actually so I don't know if
you were I don't know if you knew about
so this guy this kid challenged Mike
last Friday when Mike lace of people and
uh he lost the first game he honestly
has multiple wins here I mean like Mike
Mike play play lost the first game and
then Mike kept on challenging that kind
of rematching like 10 times and like and
then finally won the last game he's like
all right I want I'm leaving and that
was it that was it the show ended we had
to pull somebody else in because the
show wasn't over he's a lot left dude
I'm getting hosed hosed no bueno love
how you locked it to her I didn't lie
don't even know how to lock the door
what are you doing kid
okay I was honey lop dessert which never
I was totally hosed and now I may be not
so hosed I don't even have a key to
unlock the door so I don't know what I
am host what am I saying by a most Oh
[Music]
quietly cost the authorities to impeach
this missplay okay okay I got to think
for a second boss
he's thanking he's thanking
what you doing here okay
nice I don't even know if it works good
good try at least all right what do we
got
I know I know this is my little moment
to take a thing
who is the guy behind you which guy are
you friends are you talking about this
guy his name is Isaac mr. Isaac when
Isaac he's you know he usually has a big
ol beard you know lumberjack beard going
on he's also like so like me he's an
amateur breakdancer you an amateur
breakdancer no that's completely a joke
I'm all of a sudden I feel like I can't
lose but it's it's it's hot thanks Mae
from V Kosh thanks mate you just show me
I need a lot of practice cool haha this
is an interesting one this is an
interesting one Wow
I think oh good good move he played a
good move hmm now I think if I take it
he has an easy draw so I can't well
that's a real bummer okay
mr. Spock says hi Isaac okay he didn't
say anything back zero respect
man I don't know should I offer this kid
a draw
that's up to you it's up to you okay
oh wow
Gary I'm pretty depressed man Gary I'm
impressed
it's gonna be a draw I didn't say why
not time all right
I didn't say that haha
you gotta love it when you beat the kids
down there do you do you try shocked
against kids oh yeah oh I like okay
there folks
we cha-cha-cha against everybody doesn't
matter if you were a kid all right
I don't know I guess he is he is pre pre
moving beating what Gary again Alice
that was your fault Tony Chen thank you
that's your fault thank you very much
so we're gonna play this guy from Russia
his name is uh you see which one is it's
said it boy wait why is he he's not on
the list
what's his name dark is it dancing dance
occur oh no it's not it's it's uh it's
dang it lost Albert Bergerac Bergerac
Sieber jockey where's like I don't know
where you are but you're not in our
queue so we can't play you max temporary
he's uh yeah max Bria ass as well so we
can ask I think Patrick Daly is I don't
know if I play Patrick Daly yeah I still
haven't done my obligatory a Halloween
gambit though mm max temporary a lot of
people you know that they wait along
nothing they get discouraged and yeah
that's true that's true
so what are you gonna do tonight you
still haven't told me you said you're
asking me like well what are you and to
know I'm a visitor today okay all right
and I want to know I was inviting girls
dude I was inviting you but you were
like I'm not really into the chick right
that was one thing i sat out of a whole
stream why would you focus on that well
what is it what would you what would you
do what would you like to do um go to
one of the let's go let's go go get a
beer Jesse skip your class skip your
class
yeah if that's your thing go ahead I'm a
big guy
this guys coming for me man this isn't
very nice hey take it easy take it easy
Patrick Daly mr. song we'll get to you
next I'll get to you next
don't worry this is evil I don't know
this guy's I like the way the spirit of
this guy is playing this somebody said
Jessi you should be stripped of your
titles that's where I'll be true for Wow
for what talking the smack no for that
for drawing allocated its goal the true
that's okay so we have two people
requesting we have MIT ok have Mitchell
Sam and I blunder my night those are two
names ok place is a pretty spicy
position I'll tell you right now Mac
Stephanie I want you playing you right
now
oh we're not impacted didn't we then we
click on Macs company was that it I have
no idea what's going on in this game oh
really no idea
so Mac Stephanie will try to get to so
we have 15 minutes left on the show we
are trying to get to the other two
people who have been waiting for a while
so whoa what right what no guarantees
and we might not have a chance we might
not have time but we'll try it's funny
when you play like 300 or something and
it gets real hectic and then you start
playing 500 that little kid was pushing
me around
oh I had to I had to work I first had to
work to get the draw and then I was I
was like maybe he's gonna give me a shot
Archie we try to do one pump so only one
shot per per person okay just because we
have a limited amount of time we have a
lot of people so one you only got that
one shot maybe tomorrow try again
tomorrow yes yep all right right right
Amaro try tomorrow it's called a chance
I'm gonna see you here can you play
against me soon I have University I am
AB Jack Pandu we try our best there's no
we're short on time so we'll probably we
definitely won't get to everybody okay
gotta say hi from oh this guy's gotta
say hi from hi all from sunny Sydney
Australia
oh nice in Hyde Park chess cool
I'm stealing this part I don't know if
it's a wise thing but I did it I know it
was a wise thing oh so so apparently the
guy from Russia Brooke Brooke shot
something like that he's back now
okay now I'm assuming that this dude
can't actually do this to me but he is
going for it
pretty all spicy stuff right there's
some real spice all right men's OHS
challenged me now too
yeah he actually just set on a - please
play me who's playing tomorrow guys
answer is good question so typically on
typically on Fridays we have Mike Homer
place two people however he is on
vacation so he's not gonna be here so
we're gonna try to get somebody don't
know who yet danny is saying some words
that I don't like so I'm not gonna say
it well we got next Jim in res is past
Women's Champion Sabina voice or right
correct so if I don't get him here
tomorrow she is gonna be here tomorrow
I don't think what's her deal tomorrow
so yeah I think so I typically are Jim
and Red's the only two days off our
Mondays and Fridays all right Mondays
and Fridays are the date days off so
even though it's her first day she might
be oh I'm not really sure about the
schedule we'll see we'll see
look at that smooth move [ __ ] before
bang so viewers asks who's the girl's
gonna be on stream sure auntie did you
guys watch late where is that ladies
night play play the people is that the
title play the ladies yeah oh doors are
places as a official title did you guys
enjoy that show that was our first-ever
dorset and the girls play the people let
us know if you enjoyed it if so then we
will try to do it more
okay so how do you Danny how do you stop
that uh whatever it's cool whatever it's
cool I'm just gonna back it out I'm just
gonna back it up this is the spice whoa
I don't think that was nice okay just
take that okay Patrick Daly
what's the radiative forcing everyone be
introduced to my Bischoff's keys oh look
at that fish up pay oh I'm up peace
what's going on hello well Leo Leo
Narborough DaVinci says good afternoon
guys how's it going man thanks for
joining us these bishops are being a
real drag dude you know yes we somebody
says yes we enjoyed or sir and the
ladies good okay cool
we will they said it's fun all right we
might try that again
well probably we'll try that again man
this guy it's just relentless with this
down is pspace just coming up coming up
coming up
all right you win I'll take this thing
I better watch it I better watch it
buddy
he's coming here with Miss check-offs
keys watch it nah
he's a screwed me here you're me you're
a full minute ahead your other piece am
I allowed to have some anxiety here can
I just have my anxiety it isn't it like
when you get your GM title doesn't that
automatically just mean you can't have
anxiety just calm all the time comment
collected and win no hectic greetings
from Brazil
Giovanni limbo Oh cruel Brazil awesome
thank you for joining us thank you for
joining us Jessie give me some time to
breathe Tony ah yep all right it's time
for this rook to come out somehow right
isn't it time for the rook to have his
crook I I thought you were just Hakeem
keeping that rook in the corner just
because you wanted to give him him a
chance and that now with this this was a
really boring move I just did with Queen
F I'm not really in the spirit of the
Halloween gambit which I never got the
chance to play no one played e5 against
me I play d4 I think every game oh he
doesn't want to go down that dark road
somebody this is almost a dead row yeah
that's on purpose yeah
all right good job oh yeah we have time
for what one one more game possibly all
right you decide buddy which which one
champ let's go with that guy in Russia
he's been what's this right there a
berserker job now let me ask you some my
friend now are you still traumatized by
Tracy is that something that is gonna
stop you from enjoying whatever activity
that you're afraid of telling me you're
gonna do tonight I just told you what I
was gonna do tonight let's go get a beer
I'm gonna beer let's go you want to go
this is three oh my Fred holy moley here
it comes oh here goes the French I got
to do something more spicy whoa not the
French
yeah here it comes this will be a quick
end maybe it will have another one after
this you know all right so this guy
moves so fast I can't even see the moves
so we will have one more game after this
and mitchellson you're up okay calm down
calm down
stop with the sad face faces we're
playing you an hour a lot last game last
game a little spice going on
somebody said all GM's love beer not
feeling so good okay all right miss
yu-san we're playing you in the last
game I saw myself seeing this on
yourselff is Burt Bergerac Burt Jaco is
that how you pronounce it I don't know
I've English is not my first language so
well you know it's hard is that true it
is true yes I actually uh my family
emigrated to the US when I was eight
eight just her Nate I think Barack is
playing fine he's got a slightly worse
position but it beats fine that's what
surprises me a little bit but
here dunt the Dom Baraka Bert Bert Xhaka
burn all right what do we are you
winning
[Music]
Oh anyways why do I have stuff to face
that question am i winning cuz people
are wondering are you winning whoa take
it easy over there buddy
jeez Bridge Aquaman just slowed down a
little bit with the violence all right
he he's a young young man he's gonna go
slay this guy oh he's gonna push okay
okay all right I get out of Dodge here
but I like it
I know III think Baraka is now doing
fine he's just taken relentlessly and uh
okay god that was a little heart Wow
heart written I was little I was at her
I've heard that gassing Lois from Jessie
yeah right there
what are you doing buddy
all right everywhere Jacque Hawaii you
were doing great buddy oh one more one
more
all right try one more you decide will
so Amit Mitchell sands all right three
two a little bit more civilized all
right this is our last game everybody
George okay you you played well man you
late you you played it kind of like it
it got a little messy in the opening but
then you played like a king's indian
style madman attack that's it you've got
to do Mitchell son Mitchell son buddy
Bergerac I just uh
just gave you three smiley faces yeah
all right
that's pretty fun all right all right we
got to play something else who else we
got here i blundered my knight Tigre 2
Moret
what me I'm aborted what's he didn't he
wasn't there he wasn't there
how about I blended my night looks like
he's been waiting the law yeah I hear we
don't like that
Mithras I know I don't know what
happened game aborted that's that's a
last chance for the Halloween gambit Oh
buddy oh I didn't think you could do
this
and it so someone so bars are saying
isn't kh3 like a Chin Ho Hotel for like
the Berber Jaco name is that true
British uh-huh
maybe I've no idea no idea my King Falls
okay so everyone this is our last game
we do not have any any time after this
challenge us tomorrow okay I'm going for
it I'm going for it buddy
are you ready uh yep I'm gonna go for a
snack
let's do it a little bit of everybody
loves sex it's cool there you go yeah I
did it dude
was it good I don't know but I did it
max Stephanie um sorry bro
sorry bro no more time maybe maybe
tomorrow check to the misérable King
oh yeah that's a check Wow
Oh so apparently Mitchell sands phone
crashed so that's why games got boring
okay well you lost your chance so sorry
about that
maybe next time okay it's been nice
watching the stream gents
when will you be streaming again so our
next stream is tomorrow 3:00 p.m. local
time so same time as this show today
join us so this is Jesse's last day here
so he won't be on stream tomorrow we
don't even know who we're gonna be
having on stream tomorrow so we will let
you know when we start the show it's
going to be okay
even him up a rook I'm like oh no I got
anxiety hmm anxiety
that's a having so a lot of people how
about this this bar where they're
playing a bunch of like games from the
80s you like going to that place yeah
you want to I don't know anything about
it I just know bench that's been
Simone's favorite bar okay I mean it's
it's like a block away from you yeah you
have a favorite place around here you
like to go to so like I'm pretty big
into like microbrews so there's there's
a whole bunch here in st. Louis the one
closest to where I live is living so I
live in South City st. Louis South City
so that's about 15 even with traffic
about and most 15 minutes away from here
by car so the closest brewery is urban
chestnut and I try to go there Melyssa
time and what about what about places to
eat or just hang out right in this
neighborhood right in this neighborhood
so I mean this is like the best in like
we have a whole bunch of restaurants
you've got asking what will my favorite
so there's as far as eating ghosts I
would have to say so I was it's about
like two or three blocks from here
there's this place called barbecues
barbecue saloon Oh barbecue yeah so it's
like it's a lot of whiskey's and good
barbecue they have like specialty stuff
like I remember one time I had alligator
ribs and I was like wow that's pretty
interesting so what do you mean have you
been eating around here lately this time
around not so much but you know last
time I was doing the commentary for as
the summertime and
we're doing commentary and I was hanging
out a lot yeah there's a couple of
places there's that taco place down the
other way coming bucks that was real
cool and then I was hanging out cuz I
was watching a lot of soccer because it
was both Women's World Cup and there was
some other stuff going on and I was
watching out there there's a bar ISA can
sit outside kind of maybe a block before
you hit that barbecue saloon okay yes I
was watching over there a block before
barbecue soon yes it's also kind of
barbecue ish and it's on the right-hand
side and if they got out outside seating
with the TV oh yeah that place is uh
yeah places I think you're fairly new
okay that's great okay I like that
okay Patrick Davis I thank you for the
game Jesse he said haha I look at the
report if I played if I played I move 14
played h6 instead of H takes g6
stockfish says I was +2 okay nice and
one of our viewers are saying Wesley
wins and the game number two against
Magnus oh wow it's 2-2 against Magnus
nice guys get your act together
alright calm down calm down Salter back
calm down Oh Tracy's here to celebrate
her way Tracy's here come on in have a
seat
chairs going happen this here Tracy won
twice as we recall say it all you want
say it all you want check
oh that's it all right good game I would
pay attention against I don't even know
is over all right good game nice try
nice try
yeah all right we are officially out of
time we have to go join us tomorrow same
time 3 p.m. local time and we will see
who can complain against you guys no
idea yet all right and right into the
club and say bring Jesse back bring him
back
all right thank you guys all right cool
all right so we're not
you